-Big show tonight.
Guys,
if you're watching from home,
you're in for a great show.
If you're watching from jail,
then you probably
work for the president.
[ Laughter ]
That's right today was
the big sentencing hearing
for Trump's former lawyer,
Michael Cohen.
He got 36 months in prison,
or as Trump puts it,
[As Trump] that's like,
20 years.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] That's right.
Cohen got three years
for arranging
illegal hush-money payments
for Trump.
But Cohen said,
"Could have been worse.
I could have been sentenced to
be White House Chief of Staff."
That would've been --
if you don't remember Cohen,
here he is.
There, yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
He looks pretty innocent to me.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
If you saw that guy
on an episode
of "Law and Order" you'd be
like, he did it.
Come on.
[ Laughter ]
Come on, give me a break.
I saw that today in court an
artist did a sketch of Cohen.
Can we see that?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, man.
He looks like every dad
finding out
their daughter was cast
on "The Bachelor."
[ Laughter ]
And you go, oh my God.
Get this,
Cohen also had to pay
more than $1 million
in restitution.
When Trump heard that
he was like,
[As Trump]
$1 million for restitution?
She must have been good.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this,
Trump said that
he'll shut down the government
if Congress doesn't give him
money for his border wall.
So Democrats are just going to
show Trump a photo
of the Great Wall of China,
and tell him
it's already been built.
[ Laughter ]
We did it.
[ Applause ]
It looks beautiful.
I like it.
Well, Trump met with
Nancy Pelosi
and Chuck Schumer about
the border wall yesterday,
and it made him so angry
that threw a folder
full of papers across the room.
Yeah, it was mess.
There was
resignation letters everywhere.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
During their Oval Office
meeting, Trump, Schumer,
and Pelosi, got into
a heated argument
over funding
for the border wall.
The photos from the meeting
are really interesting.
Take a look at this.
This is when Trump said
that he'd shut down
the government if he doesn't get
funding for wall.
Take a look at
a few other moments.
This is when Trump
tried handing his Christmas list
to Chuck Schumer.
[ Laughter ]
This is when Nancy Pelosi
got so frustrated
that she tried ordering
a cosmo.
[ Laughter ]
This is when Trump started
shouting out spoilers
to the new "Aquaman" movie.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, don't tell me.
Oh, this is when Trump
tried to break the tension,
and started beat boxing.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, this is when
Mike Pence shifted into
low power mode, right before
his battery ran out.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And get this,
on Fox News last night,
they showed all the finalists
for "Time" magazine's
Person of the Year, but there
was a typo in someone's name.
See if you can find it.
Take a look.
-You had Putin.
You have Blasey Ford, J.M.,
and then you had,
it says David Trump on my sheet,
but I assume
they mean Donald Trump.
-What? David Trump.
-David Trump. On Fox News.
-President was like,
[As Trump] "Wow.
I've been saying it wrong
the whole time."
[ Laughter ]
"Says there, David.
I'm David Trump?"
[ Normal voice ] Well, you guys,
we're in the middle
of the holiday season.
A lot of companies are having
their big
year-end holiday parties.
Now, dressing up for those
are always fun,
but picking the right outfit can
be a little stressful.
So here to share some tips
on what to wear
to an office holiday party
is independent expert,
Andrew Carnes.
Andrew?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Yes, good.
-What, how are you doing? Well?
-Yes, very good. How are you?
-I'm doing great.
Everything's good?
-Things are bad.
-The wife is good?
-No things are --
-The kids are good?
-Everything is --
all of it is bad.
[ Laughter ]
-Andrew, welcome to the show.
-Yes, nice to see you
for the first time.
[ Laughter ]
-Welcome back.
-Yeah.
-As I said.
Andrew,
as an independent expert,
can you give us some tips
on what to wear
to an office holiday party?
-I'd love nothing more.
[ Laughter ]
Now, in planning for
an office holiday party,
it's important to look stylish
yet joyful.
-Okay.
-This outfit, for instance --
[ Laughter ] -
-Oh, that's you there.
-Yeah.
-That's a picture of you.
-Now this is both mindful
of an office dress code
as well as evocative
of the holiday spirit,
which is reflected in
the crimson-colored
argyle sweater,
and Santa Claus head hat.
-The head hat.
-The head hat, yes.
-Now what should someone
not wear to
an office holiday party?
-Something like this.
[ Laughter ]
Now.
-Oh, no, man. Come on. Andrew.
-Now, while the red coloring
does conjure up
the Christmas spirit --
-Okay.
-The nipple-colored jacket,
and groin garnish --
-Yeah, groin garnish, yeah.
-Sorry, nipple crops,
I meant to say.
Now, this person really looks
like garbage.
Sometimes it's better
to let a Christmas present
remain unwrapped.
-That's good.
Now, Andrew,
so you're saying that
the first outfit is good,
but the second one is bad.
-Yes, it's slightly difficult.
It's confusing.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah.
Perhaps I should give
another example.
-That's a great idea.
-Now, if you're looking for
an appropriate party outfit,
this one's a winner.
-Okay, okay.
-Approachable.
-That's the picture you want
to go with there Andrew?
Is that you --
-The outfit is a winner.
-Yep.
-Seasonal.
-Uh-huh.
-Inoffensive.
That's right.
-Snazzy necktie with frostman
the snowman on it.
[ Laughter ]
-Frostman the snowman. Yep.
Frosty the snowman.
-I believe --
I think it's frostman.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-This outfit --
-Yeah, it's very nice.
-Conveys Christmas warmth,
as well as a respect
for the institutions
of the modern American office.
-All right good.
-Yeah.
-That's very, very good.
-But what does not convey
respect is this.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no, no, no.
That's too much now.
You've gone too far.
-Now, while the
oriental headdress brings to
mind Christmas decorations
of yore.
-Yeah, no yeah.
-The salmon-colored
one-piece brings to mind
a bloated male member
of the Rockettes.
-Yeah.
-Wearing something like this
would put you on both Santa's,
and HR's naughty list.
Does that all make sense?
-I'm afraid not.
I'm still actually confused.
-Oh, understandable.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Now to clarify,
this is an excellent outfit
to wear to an office party.
-Yeah, okay.
These are more examples.
-This, however, is not.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-All right, well that's --
-It's kind of a Hanukkah theme.
-That's it. I think I'm getting
it, but I'm not quite there yet.
-Fine.
This is not acceptable,
while this
is even less acceptable.
-Okay, I understand --
I see what you're saying.
-Yeah.
-So, you're saying that
this is something
you should not wear.
-Correct.
-And this is also something
you should not wear.
-Yes. Yes. Correct.
-Yeah.
-And of course it wouldn't be
the holiday season if I didn't
remind you not to wear these.
-No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-My gosh.
Get out of here!
-No.
-Me get out of here?
How about you get out.
Oh, my gosh.
Get him out of here.
Get out of here.
Get -- no. That way.
I don't care. Get out of here!
My God.
What the heck? Wow.
-Wow.
-That was offensive.
That was offensive!
-He's an expert?
-He's an independent expert.
-That's awful.
-That is just terrible.
I apologize.
-Why would you do that?
-I apologize to you.
-Oh my gosh.
-I feel like a fool.
[ Laughter ]
-Letting that person
on the show.
I don't think you taught
anybody anything.
-Is that right?
-Yeah, I don't think you did.
-Do you feel like --
you must feel like a fool.
-I feel like a damn fool.
[ Laughter ]
-Finally, check this out.
After an accident at
a chocolate factory in Germany,
tons of liquid chocolate spilled
out onto the streets.
Take a look at this.
Yep, when police arrived on the
scene, they were like,
please God,
let that be chocolate.
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody!